welcome to heavy spoilers i'm your host
ryan airy that's right welcome to the
multiverse baby and this timeline this
is my youtube channel where i am just
like paul i always finish first and
leave you unsatisfied you some of a
[ __ ] anyway welcome guys and after nine
weeks of what if we're now at the finale
of the show the last episode is packed
with easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed we also know a lot
more about season 2 now as well as the
episode that was cut which should clear
up some confusion over the series namely
why is gamora anyway heavy spoilers are
now in full effect so if you haven't had
a chance to check out the episode then i
highly suggest that you check out now i
need you guys to hit that thumbs up
button one last time and make sure you
subscribe for upcoming breakdowns on the
eternals in hawkeye without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into episode nine of what if
okay so after infinite ultron party poop
doors big bash it was only right that we
learned about the origin story of the
character along with where he came from
episode 8 told us how he rose to power
and i found it absolutely hilarious how
the entire multiverse was gonna be
destroyed by a disgruntled stalk robot
the entry ended with the watcher being
unable to live with his own failure and
this had brought him back to doctor
strange supreme it was very much a
situation where the character came out
saying well well well how'd they turn
tables but it is nice to see him back in
this entry for weeks we've been teased a
big multiversal avengers-esque episode
with all the characters from across the
season and it's awesome seeing the
series pay off with this in the finale
now the concept of the episode is what
if the watcher broke his oath and
interfered yesterday we got the promo
for the show which hinted out what this
would do with the multiverse cracking
directly because of it as with all the
promos we watched a tv atv screen but
instead of it showing a divergence huatu
appeared in the reflection and that
broke it which hints towards a direction
that things take towards the end the
watchers do take a vow to never
interfere only to observe but over the
years uatu has actually got involved
several times in the comics he's saved
the fantastic four several times been
punched by the red hulk and shout outs
comicbook.com for reminding me that he
once bit a monster disguised as a puppy
nice guy anyway the idea of breaking an
oath is of course reflected in strange
supreme who broke the hippocratic oath
when he took a life this is something
that the doc wrestled with in his first
solo movie and i love how there's this
idea of these two earth breakers being
brought together
now we open with captain carter taking
on the same mission that steve did at
the start of the winter soldier this
involved the lemerian star being
hijacked by batroc the lipper she's
joined by black widow who has the same
bangs as she did in that movie and also
crossbones who originally carried out
their mission with steve now we can see
that captain carter has changed the logo
on her chest from her first what if
episode the new costume is way more in
line with what steve had with the union
jack now being silver much in the same
way that his costume evolved to be the
dialogue is almost exactly the same as
the exchange that steven blackwidow had
with aladdin mentioning bernard from
accounting in the winter soldier it was
actually lillian from accounting which
steve said he wasn't ready for because
of her lip piercing this time peggy's
turned off because bernard is a boring
name but that name could be a nod to
geoffrey wright's character from
westworld wright voices the watcher so
it could be a nod to bernard or it could
be a reach anyway widow brings up steve
but peggy plays it off as a joke however
we do learn that he's pretty much alive
in this universe peggy jumps out the
quinjet without a parachute and she
lands on the starter fight batroc in a
scene that's very similar to the
exchange in the winter soldier occur to
the dairy queen that we last saw ego
enter at the end of episode 2 and this
location of course pulled from the
opening of guardians vol 2 as being the
place where igor left his seed as peter
quill never became starlord in this
universe he remained on earth and ego
simply went along to harvest his son's
powers to take over the universe
in guardians i'm guessing he was only
nice to his son because he'd heard of
the legend of starlord and was worried
that he might be able to stop him as an
earthling he's pretty useless but
luckily t'challa shows up and saves the
day now there is a clue that t'challa
would be coming to the rescue as when we
cut to the dairy queen we can catch the
mandela coming in i don't think ego is
killed as the planet that it really is
isn't destroyed but the body he brought
to earth probably is taken out due to
the explosive now t'challa is taken by
the giant baby man cape dude and it's in
the next scene that there might be a bit
of confusion at this point we're
introduced to thinora who's a brand new
character for the series though she
appeared in the posters she never
actually got a standalone episode but
there are rumors that this was initially
supposed to be a part of the season in
an interview with entertainment weekly
showrunner ac bradley confirmed that the
series was originally meant to be 10
episodes long but due to the way that
the world's been one of them needed to
be pushed back to season 2. they didn't
want to sacrifice the finale and
unfortunately it seems that no matter
what gamora is getting dropped now
bradley's saying that it was going to be
a lion upbeat tony stark episode and
from what we've seen this entry we can
pretty much confirm that this was going
to be the tony ghost to sakhar one
according to the plot leaks that were
released in the build-up to the show
tony was originally going to launch the
nuke into space at the end of the
avengers and it would hit thanos's ship
instead of the chittari one from this
point he actually missed the portal and
was taken to sakura where he became a
gladiator from what the leaks said
gamora then used the opportunity of the
ship being in turmoil to kill her father
and she also decided to enact revenge on
tony tony was then apparently going to
become a gladiator and then donora would
hunt him down in order to make sure the
stones could never be collected
or something along those lines here look
i haven't seen the episode stop asking
questions now we'll talk about whether
this lines up with a final thing later
on but it's also important to know that
bradley also confirmed that the watcher
was intentionally getting closer and
closer every single episode this is
something that we theorized and it makes
me think that the order of seven and
five was switched so that the midpoint
was wilder and that the final three
episodes all tied together they also
stated that the watcher is very much
meant to be a metaphor for the audience
who have slowly been pulled into the
series and also the events i actually
think that metaphor works really well
especially with one of the speeches in
the episode and it kind of personifies
the slow burn that the season has been
in the build-up to this finale now on
nevada it's in never never now on never
delia we see the infinity gauntlet being
melted down so i'm guessing that tony
talked her out of her quest for revenge
we also see etry the dwarf from infinity
war and tony has the gladiator
hulkbuster suit on he wants to put a
suit of armor around the galaxy and this
is of course similar to the idea that
created ultron and ended up leading to
the biggest threat in the multiverse the
watcher calls her the destroyer of
thanos and this makes me think that
there is some credibility to the leaks
also big spoiler for next season yeah
she teams up with tony now we cut to
wakanda and see the us invasion led by
peppa potts and shuri and i really
appreciate that they took the time to
answer a lot of the cliffhangers that we
were left with in this season now we
catch thor in vegas fighting off ultron
bots in a clip that was shown in the
trailer for the series the god of
thunder complains that he was about to
go on a date and that there was gonna be
flowers which is something that he gave
to jane at the end of episode 7. you
might also notice that he has a cape on
in this opening but that he doesn't for
the rest of the episode this is because
if you slow down the footage you can
actually catch a bot grab it as it
latches onto his shoulders and he then
throws it along with this stylish
garment the watcher arrives and picks
him up and this shot looks very similar
to king kong namely when the giant
gorilla picked up andaro he reacts in
the exact same way and it's hilarious
just watching him scream together the
heroes arrive in the pub from the first
episode and this is pulled directly from
peggy's memories a photo of steve hangs
on the wall and strange gives thor a
beer which seems to refill itself with
magic due to him drinking from it and
then it being full in the next shot now
i love how killmonger peers into the
head of an ultron bot that thor brought
and he did use drones in his own episode
so him being obsessed over this just
makes a lot of sense by the end of the
entry he does reveal his true plan and
it's nice that they foreshadow it in
this moment now what's also great is
seeing him and t'challa on screen
together as in the mcu the ladder was
responsible for his death whereas in
this kill manga's universe he of course
killed the character thor attempts to
leave but he finds that they're actually
floating in a void outside of time and
space the exterior of the pub is
surrounded by the magical glyphs typical
of strange and it's some really nice
attention to detail from this point on
both uatu and strange fill them in not
only on ultron but also the infinity
stones this scene and the way that it's
presented is almost beat for beat the
way that wong talks about them in
infinity war including the imagery of
them floating above the heads of the
onlookers they put together a plan and
were also introduced to the infinity
crusher which apparently apparently is
capable of destroying the stones and
turning them to atoms thor goes off in a
bit of a rant and shows that he doesn't
really understand what's going on but in
his vanity and arrogance he can't admit
that so he just says everyone else
doesn't understand interestingly they
actually changed this scene up from the
trailer and marvel removed certain
characters and also altered the framing
so that things wouldn't be spoiled but i
got you now there's an amazing con
before the storm scene in which the
heroes all interact with each other and
drink to what could be their deaths
there's some really nice exchanges here
including carter and strange who discuss
how steve rogers took the serum on his
universe which makes peggy happy knowing
that he's out there somewhere we can
also catch the leopard-like spots on
killmonger's suit and this makes me
think that he's dropped the moniker of
the panther because of the legacy that
comes with it also there's the saying a
leopard never changes its spots and in
this episode we see that killmonger is
still pretty much a bad guy they toast
to the guardians of the multiverse and
you know what i really really like this
team i'd love to see a live action
version of them at some point and it
would be amazing to come across them in
something like doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness unfortunately
they're frolicking well namely thor's
frolicking it attracts ultron who
appears in the sky in a similar vein to
how the watcher does ultron arrives and
strange gives them a protection spell
which looks very similar to what we've
seen the eternals carrying out in the
trailer in that they were encased in
golden light so i'm guessing that it
might be along the same lines of what's
going on here though completely ignores
the plan and tries to take on ultron
himself but it's about as useless as
this video is after new rock stars have
uploaded theirs be honest yeah you'll
never watch this again now the group
decided to work as a team instead and
strange uses the multiplication spell on
malnia in order to attack the machine at
every angle this was something that he
carried out on thanos and the group then
duke it out in the air which leads to an
awesome action scene normally mortals
are unable to hold an infinity stone but
t'challa can because of the protection
spell they exit after strange brings
across ghouls from the zombie universe
and amongst these we can catch captain
america hawkeye and also the falcon we
don't get a resolution to the thanos
zombie and wakanda however we see the
return of scholar witch who unleashes
her powers before ultron can say i don't
even know who you are he destroys the
planet and her along with it the heroes
are transported to the universe in which
ultron rose up and here they come face
to face with natasha romanov peggy
proves she knows her by mentioning her
father's name ivan which was also said
to her by red skull in endgame however
she also says her da is alexi which is
the real name of the red guardian who of
course looked after her as a child
before they can become bffs in this
world ultron arrives in wrecks shop but
we see how strong strange's magic is as
it counters ultron's ability to destroy
this universe he absorbs the blast
created by ultron and it could be that
he's got some ultra interior motives in
absorbing his abilities so that he can
become stronger and appear in future
properties the guardians wail on ultron
and i loved watching the two shield
bearers just constantly battering him
from every angle as they fight over the
stones there's an amazing moment in
which we bring focus to the soul as
people desperately try and grab it but
using the time stone ultron manages to
get it however strange summons the
shumagora powers he absorbed and manages
to give ultron a threat he's not able to
defend against so easily also was anyone
else cracking up a thought shouting
vegas during this i really like that bit
though the stones are seemingly
destroyed with the infinity crusher but
we learned that because it was designed
to eradicate them in gamora's universe
it actually has little effect on the
ones on ultron's chest we get a shot of
the group all standing together as the
camera pans around them and this is of
course aping the infamous avengers
moment from their first team at movie
realizing that strange is the strongest
one there is and that he must break him
in order to take out the rest of the
team he attacks him head on it's during
this time that black widow and carter
are blasted back to the former's bike
and at this point she spots the zola
arrow
now last week black widow and hawkeye
headed out to the base in siberia that
we saw in civil war not only were the
tanks there from the scene with zemo but
they also discovered a copy of arnhem
zola the plan was to make him into a
computer virus and i forgot to mention
last week that this actually pulls from
the pages of age of ultron in the book
ultron ended up taking over the world
and then wolverine and sue storm
traveled back in time to stop hank pym
from creating him wolverine ended up
killing pym but upon returning to the
present he found that the world was a
vastly different place because one of
the main avengers wasn't there to save
the day at key points in their history
wolverine was captured by the defenders
and a battle scored tony stark
interrogated him in order to learn the
truth luckily wolverine managed to
escape when morgana lafaye attacked and
she killed the whole defenders which
meant wolverine basically had to travel
back to the past to stop himself from
killing hank he managed to do this and
instead they created a virus with an
ultron this would enable hank to shut it
down when it attacked and it was a lot
of timey winey wibbly wobbly stuff hank
purposely erased the memory of this so
that all the clashes that ultron had
with the avengers would remain unchanged
as the last thing he wanted to do was
screw up time even more they needed
everything to play out exactly the same
way as it was supposed to and in the
present when ultron launched his attack
hank ended up initiating the shutdown
though it saved the day all the
travelling back and forth through time
did somewhat break the multiverse and
the memories of the previous timeline
came flooding back to the heroes this
appeared in somewhat of a glass
shattering image which of course is
something that what if is also used now
this event would lead into secret wars
which is likely coming down the line at
some point once the universe just ends
up going to hell anyway really
interesting to kind of tied into that
and i love how they brought that story
motif across now nat and peggy rush
towards ultron and the former embraces
her in a hawkeye and says this is for
you clint she fires the virus arrow and
it's a brilliant moment that i
absolutely loved peggy manages to lift
up the mask on ultron's head and because
of this the arrow can enter the vision's
eye takes away his vision hey now much
in the same way that ultron shuts down
jarvis at the start of age of ultron in
the body of the vision zola destroys him
however the episode isn't over yet and
killmonger absorbs not only the armor
but also the stones along with it he
tempts the characters with the chance to
change the tragedies that have happened
to them however they refuse and
killmonger reveals his true plan which
is still of course domination now we get
an amazing call back to the comics when
zola stands up in the vision's body and
we can see his face projecting like a
teletubby from the stomach in the comics
zoller actually ended up getting put
into a mechanical machine and much in
the same way that it appears here a
screen projecting his face was put
across the stomach widow kind of spoils
the hydra twist for peggy who of course
wouldn't know at this point due to her
leaving at the start of the winter
soldier strange realizes that the plan
was to separate the stones from the body
so that they couldn't cause more damage
and he creates a pocket dimension
similar the one that we saw at the end
of his solo episode this is then
entrusted to him as he returns to his
destroyed reality in order to apparently
watch over everything i do think that
the character will be tempted to change
things though and that he may even take
the stones for himself and try to break
free of this there is of course a darker
side within him an eternity is a mighty
long time the watcher returns the heroes
to the moment that they left and peggy
gives one more glance to steve's picture
before realizing it's her duty to go
back to the time that she was in as we
know with steve he would be reunited
with the one he loved but things change
up for the post-credits scene with it
being revealed that he's actually been
put in stasis inside the hydra stomper
this means that peggy can remain in the
present instead of traveling back in
time and that her character can go on
past the events of end game in her
universe it's a very touching way to
close things out but i will talk about
that later on in the video now all
that's left are widow and the watcher
and she gives a very fourth wall
breaking speech about how the characters
in superhero movies are just stories to
yuatu and those that look on whilst that
initially says that this makes them
insignificant the watcher admits that he
pretty much wouldn't have a youtube
channel if these characters didn't exist
it means everything to him and he takes
her to a world that lost their widow
namely the one from episode 3. with just
captain marvel and captain america
things have spiraled into a mess but
widow's here to save the world from
loki's invasion i very much feel like
this is in line with age of ultron
namely how hank being removed from the
timeline caused disastrous things to
happen however widow is back and he uses
the scepter to control loki's mind and
basically call off the attack we catch
the heroes on their own worlds and this
includes t'challa and peter quill the
latter of whom is firing a blaster i'm
guessing that this means he'll
eventually go on to become a ravager and
it's nice that this cliffhanger has
somewhat of a happy ending gamora is
reunited with sir cartoni thor gets to
be with jane and the watcher vows to
protect the multiverse and all of his
stories in the post-credits scene we cut
back to peggy's mission and rather than
keeping things to herself like in the
winter soldier widow tells peggy what
she's found as we mentioned this is
revealed to be the hydra stomper and
though we don't get it fully confirmed
yet we don't get to confirm that it's
steve
widow says there's someone inside and
the way she says it i think definitely
makes it seem like it's him and that
closes out the episode and the season
and i have to say i really love this
finale we do have some cliffhangers
still up in the air at the end of the
season like the zombie thanos one but
overall i think they did a great job of
giving us resolution in this entry there
are rumors that we will be getting a
live action version of the zombie
universe at some point and i would
absolutely love every season to have an
entry set in that world and maybe they
didn't answer it because they're
planning something in the future
now as with my thoughts on the series i
don't think it's any secret that i've
enjoyed it i know it's had its ups and
downs looking back on it i think that
it's worked really well getting to know
these characters week to week before
they come in for a big fight at the end
has been the best way that they could
have handled it and though i did get a
bit fed up of watching tony stark die
over and over i think the series has
accomplished its goals the season set
out to tell some fun and depressing
stories that's a major event in the mcu
to give us some great multiverse stories
that show what the heroes would have
ended up like had some minor elements
changed i'm really happy to actually
gave us a quote-unquote age of ultron
story as i must admit that i was a bit
disappointed when the film ended up
being so different to the source
material however i do think that they
did things in a way that it would please
people who love that book without
alienating newcomers who haven't had the
chance to read it overall the series was
really enjoyable and i've had a lot of
fun with it every week there were some
great performances in here and emotional
ones too especially as we know this is
the last thing to be released starring
chadwick boseman what if is a great
start to the multiverse and i'm
confident that they can take what worked
about this one remove what didn't and
make a brilliant season two now as for
season two we know that the cancelled
tenth episode in this one will be
carried over to that whether the leaks
turn out to be true and it is the tony
goes to zakar one we won't know for a
while but that's a pretty interesting
way to kick start the new season there's
also the fact that the showrunners have
said captain carter will also star in
the second season and be somewhat of a
threat that ties everything together i
really can't wait to see how they get
her involved on top of all of this and
that could massively shape the future
season as for the future of marvel we
have a lot to look forward to and the
eternals is dropping on the 5th of
november which is less than a month away
there's also hawkeye which is due to
debut on the 24th and the first trailer
for that looks really fun with a lot of
call backs to the comics feels like it's
ripped right out of the hawkeye story
especially with the cars and stuff so i
think it's going to be jam-packed with
easter eggs that'll definitely be
breaking down yesterday it was also
announced by marvel india that blade
will be releasing october 7th 2022 i
don't know if this is a mistake or
they've just managed to keep it so
secret that even the spoiler man didn't
know about it but it's a pretty big
announcement it's also been reported
that strange supreme will be appearing
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness so this show might pay off a lot
more than people think in the end doing
this every wednesday with you guys has
been super fun for me and i hope you've
enjoyed it just as much as i have really
appreciate your support and we will of
course be back before you know it with
another marvel breakdown now obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
episode so make sure you comment below
and let me know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the phase 3mc box on the
30th of october and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want emails to
watch then make sure you check our
breakdown of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness leaks that went
around recently which will be linked on
screen right now we talk about what
we've been told about the film as well
as the general leaks floating about the
internet so definitely go and watch it
right after this without the way thank
you for singing through the video i've
been writing it oh so i've been i've
been paul i'll see you next time take
care peace